so
i think one of the most beautiful ideas
uh philosophically and technically is uh
of a virtual machine the java virtual
machine
um again apologize to romanticize things
but uh
how did the idea of the jvm come to be
how to you radical of an idea it is
because it seems to me
to be just a really interesting idea in
the history of programming
so and what is it so the java virtual
machine
you can think of it in different ways
because it was carefully designed to
have
different ways of viewing it so one view
of it that most people
don't really realize is there is that
you can
um view it as sort of an encoding
of the abstract syntax tree in reverse
polish notation
um i don't know if that makes any sense
at all
i could explain it and that would blow
all of our time yeah um
but the other way to think of it um and
the way that
it ends up being explained is that
it's it's like the the instruction set
of
an abstract machine that's designed such
that you can
translate that abstract machine to a
physical machine
and the reason that that's important
so if you wind back to the early 90s
when we were talking to all of these
these companies doing consumer
electronics
and you talked to the purchasing people
there were interesting conversations
with purchasing
um so if you look at how you know these
you know these devices come together
they're
sheet metal and gears and circuit boards
and capacitors
and resistors and stuff
and everything you buy has multiple
sources
right so you can buy a capacitor
from here you can buy a capacitor from
there
and you've got kind of a market so you
know so that the
you can actually get a decent price for
a capacitor
um but
cpus and particularly in the early 90s
um cpus were
all different and all proprietary
so if you use the chip from intel
you had to be an intel customer for the
end of
till the end of time because if you
wrote a bunch of software
you know when you wrote software using
whatever technique you wanted and c was
particularly bad about this because
there was a lot of properties of the
underlying machine
that came through so you were stuck so
the code you wrote you were stuck to
that particular machine
you were stuck to that particular
machine which meant that
they couldn't decide you know intel is
screwing us
um i'll start buying chips from
you know bob's better chips
this drove the like the purchasing
people
absolutely insane
that that they would they were welded
into this decision
and it would have they would have to
make this decision before the first line
of software was written
it's funny that you're talking about the
purchasing people so that's one
perspective right
it's you could there's a lot of other
perspectives that all
probably hated this idea right but from
a technical aspect just like
the creation of an abstraction layer
uh agnostic to the underlying machine
from the perspective of the developer i
mean that's brilliant
right well and and and and
you know you know so that's like across
the spectrum of
providers of chips but then there's also
the the time
thing because um you know as you went
from one generation to the next
generation to the next generation they
were all different
and you would often have to rewrite your
software i mean degenerations of uh
cpu of machines of different kinds yeah
so
so like like like one of the things that
sucked about a year out of my life was
when
son went from the the motorola
68010 processor to the
68020 processor then they had a number
of differences
and one of them hit us really hard and i
ended up being
the the point guy on the worst case of
where
the new instruction cache architecture
heard us
well okay so i mean so one of the
i mean okay so yeah you you articulate a
really clear
fundamental problem in all of computing
but
how where do you get the guts to think
we can actually solve this you know in
our conversations
with you know all these vendors you know
these these
problems started to to show up
and
i kind of had this epiphany
because it reminded me of
a summer job that i had had in grad
school so
back in grad school my my thesis advisor
well i had two thesis advisors
for bizarre reasons um one of them was a
guy named raj reddy the other one was
bob sproul um and
raj i love ra i love both of them
but right so
the the department had bought
a bunch of like early workstations
from a company called three rivers
computer company
and three rivers computer company was a
bunch of electrical engineers who wanted
to do as little software as possible
so they knew that they'd need to have
like compilers and an os and stuff like
that and they didn't want to do any of
that
and they wanted to do that for as close
to zero money as possible
so um
what they did was they they built a
machine whose instruction set
was um the
was literally the byte code for ucsd
pascal
the p code
and so we had a bunch of software
um that was that was written
for this machine um
and for various reasons you know the
company wasn't doing terrifically well
we had all the software on these
machines and we wanted it to run on
other machines principally the backs
and um
and so raj asked me if i could
come up with a way to port all of this
software
and translate from the from from from
the
the the the perk machines to vaxis
and and i think he
you know what he had in mind was
something that would translate from like
pascal to c
or pascal to uh actually at those times
pretty much it was
you could translate to c or c and if you
didn't like translating to c
you could translate to c um
there was you know it's you know it's
like the the henry ford
you know any color you want just so long
as it's black
um and and i went
that's really hard um
and and i and i noticed that you know
and i was like
looking at stuff and i went oh i bet i
could rewrite
the p code into vax assembly code
and and then i started to realize that
you know there were some
properties of p code that made that
really easy
some properties that made it really hard
so i ended up
writing this thing that translated from
from p code on the three rivers perks
into assembly code on the backs
and i actually got higher quality
code than the c compiler
and so so everything just went got
really fast it was really easy it was
like
wow i thought that was a sleazy hack
because i was lazy and in actual fact it
worked really well
and and i and i tried to convince people
that that was maybe a good thesis topic
yeah um and nobody was
it was you know it was like nah really
that's
i mean yeah it's really it's kind of a
brilliant idea
right maybe you didn't have the
you weren't able to articulate the big
picture of it
yeah and and i think you know that was a
um a key part but so then you know
clock comes forward a few years and it's
like
we've got to be able to you know that
you know that you know if they want to
be able to switch
from you know this weird microprocessor
to that
weird and totally different
microprocessor how do you do that
and i kind of went oh
maybe by doing something kind of in the
space of
you know pascal p code you know i could
do
like multiple translators and i spent
some time thinking about that and
thinking about you know what worked and
what didn't work when i
did the the the p code to vax translator
and um i talked to some of the folks who
were involved in small talk because
small talk also did divide code
and and and then i kind of went
yeah let's that i want to do that yeah
because that act
you know and and it had the the other
advantage that
you could either interpret it or compile
it
and um interpreters are usually
easier to do but not as fast
as a compiler so i figured
good i can be lazy again um
you know so you know sometimes i think
that most of my good ideas are
um driven by laziness
and often i find that people some of
people's stupidest ideas are because
they're insufficiently lazy
um yeah
just they just want to build something
really complicated it's like it doesn't
need to be that complicated
yeah and so and so that's how that came
out and um
you know but that also turned into kind
of a
you know almost a religious position on
my part which was
which got me in in several other fights
so like like one of the things that was
a real
difference was the way that arithmetic
worked um
you know once upon a time
there were you know it wasn't always
just two's complement arithmetic
there were some machines that had once
complement arithmetic which was like
almost anything built by cdc um
and occasionally there were machines
that were decimal arithmetic
and and i was like this is crazy
you know pretty much two's complement
integer arithmetic has one
so just let's just do that just to do
that
one of the other places where there was
a lot of variability was in the way that
floating point behaved
and that was causing people throughout
the
software industry much pain because you
couldn't
do a numerical computing library that
would work on cdc and then have it work
on an ibm machine and
work on a on a deck machine um
and and as a as a part of that whole
struggle there had been this
this big body of work on
on floating point standards
and this thing emerged that came to be
called ieee 754
um which is the floating point standard
that pretty much has
take taken over the entire universe
um and and at the time i was doing java
it had pretty much completed taking over
the universe
um there were still a few pockets of
holdouts but
i was like you know it's important to be
able to say what two plus two means
um yeah and and so i went
that um and
one of the ways that i got into fights
with people was that
there were a few machines that did not
implement
ieee 754 correctly
well of course that's that's all
short-term kind of fights
i think in the in the long term i think
this vision is
won out yeah and and i think it's you
know and it worked out over time i mean
the
the biggest fights were with intel
because they had done some strange
things with rounding
they'd done some strange things with
their transcendental functions
which might turned into a mushroom cloud
of
you know weirdness and the name in the
name of optimization
but from the perspective of the
developer
that's not that's not good well their
issues with transcendental functions
were just stupid
okay so that that's that's not even a
tradeoff that's just absolutely
yeah they were they were doing range
reduction in for sine and cosine
using a slightly wrong value for pi
you